by the way the biggest practical
application of quantum computing that we
know about by far I think is simply the
simulation of quantum mechanics itself
in order to you know learn about
chemical reactions you know design maybe
new chemical processes new materials new
drugs new solar cells new
superconductors all kinds of things like
that what's the size of a quantum
computer that would be able to simulate
the you know quantum mechanical systems
themselves that would be impactful for
the real world for the kind of chemical
reactions and that kind of work what
what scalar were talking about now
you're asking a very very current
question a very big question people are
going to be racing over the next decade
to try to do useful quantum simulations
even with you know 100 or 200 cubic
quantum computers of the sort that we
expect to be able to build over the next
decade okay so that might be you know
the first application of quantum
computing that we're able to realize you
know or or maybe it will prove to be too
difficult and maybe even that will
require fault tolerance or you know will
require error correction that's an
aggressive race to come up with the one
case study kind of like the Peter shor
the with a with the idea that would just
capture the world's imagination of yeah
look we can actually do something very
yeah right but I think you know within
the next decade the best shot we have is
certainly not you know Shor's algorithm
to break cryptography you know it's just
just because it requires you know too
much in the way of error correction the
best shot we have is to do some quantum
simulation that tells the material
scientists or chemists or nuclear
physicists you know something that is
useful to them and that they didn't
already know you know and you might only
need one or two successes in order to
change some you know billion-dollar
industries right like you know the way
that people make fertilizer right now is
still based on the harbor Boetsch
process from a century ago and it is
some many-body quantum mechanics
no one really understands right if you
could design a better way to make
fertilizer right that's you know
billions of dollars right there so so so
those are sort of the applications that
people are going to be aggressively
racing toward over the next decade now I
don't know if they're gonna realize it
or not but you know it is you know
there's there sir
they certainly at least have a shot so
it's gonna be a very very interesting
next decade but just to get by what's
your intuition is if a breakthrough like
that comes with is it possible for that
breakthrough to be on fifty to a hundred
cubits or is scale a fundamental thing
like a five hundred one thousand of plus
qubits yeah so I I can tell you what the
current studies are saying you know I I
think probably better to rely on that
than my intuition but you know there
there was a group at Microsoft had a
study a few years ago that said even
with only about 100 cubits you know you
could already learn something new about
this the chemical reaction that makes
fertilizer for example the trouble is
they're talking about a hundred cubits
and about a million layers of quantum
gates okay so they're so basically
they're talking about a hundred nearly
perfect qubits so the logical qubits is
you measure exactly a hundred logical
qubits and and now you know the hard
part for the next decade is going to be
well what can we do with a hundred to
two hundred noisy qubits yeah yeah
is that an error correction
breakthroughs that might come without
and need to do thousands or millions of
yeah yeah so people are gonna be pushing
simultaneously on a bunch of different
directions one direction of course is
just making the cube it's better right
and you know there's there there is
tremendous progress there I mean you
know the fidelity is like the the the
accuracy of the qubits isn't improved by
several orders of magnitude you know in
the you know and the last decade or two
okay the second thing is designing
better our you know let's say lower
overhead error correcting codes and even
short of doing the full recursive
error correction you know there were
these error mitigation strategies that
you can use you know that may you know
allow you to eke out a useful speed-up
in the near term and then the third
thing is just taking the quantum
algorithms for simulating quantum
chemistry or materials and making them
more efficient you know and those
algorithms are already dramatically more
efficient than they were let's say five
years ago and so when you know I quoted
these estimates like you know circuit
depth of 1 million and so you know I
hope that because people will care
enough that these numbers are going to
come down
you